but first never normal
again well that's the focus of tonight's
angle
now this time of year is usually filled
with christmas parties
bustling restaurants trips to visit
loved ones this happens all over the
country but
of course because of covid for most of
us nothing seems the same
and more americans are on edge now some
are legitimately terrified of getting
the virus
there's been a lot of tragedy we know it
others want to end
lockdowns and all these rules that they
believe are arbitrary and destructive
now even conversations between friends
and between colleagues
can get heated as it did on cnbc this
morning between
andrew ross sorkin and rick santelli
now santelli rightly noted the illogical
choice to keep
things like big box stores open yet
moved to shut down restaurants there is
actually and should be an ongoing debate
as to
you know why a parking lot for a big box
store
like by my house is jam-packed not one
parking spot open
why are those people any safer than a
restaurant with plexiglass
i i just don't get it you can't tell me
that shutting down
which is the easiest answer is
necessarily the only answer
oh well then mr sorkin claimed without
evidence that
restaurants spread more covered than big
stores
the difference between a big box
retailer and a restaurant
or frankly even a a church are
so different it's unbelievable going
into the big box retailer
i disagree
500 people at a lowe's aren't any safer
than 150 people in a restaurant that
holds 600
i don't believe it sorry don't believe
me okay
and i live in an area where there's a
lot of restaurants that have fought back
and they don't have any problems
he's right people are beginning to fight
back now you saw the protest this week
outside of mack's public house which is
a bar in staten island where the owner
was arrested
for just staying open just like other
restaurants are permitted to do
just a few blocks away but the elites
like sorkin they think that they can
justify
any harm being done to working class
americans by invoking the
science well individual americans rights
and livelihoods
are expendable in this brave new
scientific world
people need to do what they're told no
questions asked you don't have to
believe it
but let me just say this you're doing a
disservice to the viewer
because the viewers need to understand
you're doing it
you are you are
i i'm sorry i'm sorry if if i
i would like to keep our viewers as
healthy as humanly possible
the idea of packing people into
restaurants i think our viewers are
smart enough to make part of those
decisions
completely different i don't think that
i'm much smarter than all the viewers
like some people do
oh wow well that debate really does
capture what's going on across america
now all of us know what a tragedy this
virus has been for so many families
but the disagreement centers on how we
as a free nation manage it
so gavin newsom gretchen whitmer and jb
pritzker
are all democrat governors whose first
impulse against covid
is to shut stuff down and strip you of
your freedoms while making of course
exceptions all the while for themselves
now we're calling it the kivocracy and
no
we aren't at all moved by the fake
apologies that always follow on when
they get caught
or calls for unity from these
co-hypocrites
that they always give that after getting
caught red-handed breaking their own
rules
now today this was fascinating alex
berenson he's been on our show so many
times
he published an email that he received
by a man who lives with his family in
northern virginia
now he and his wife have good paying
jobs that allow them to work from home
with few inconveniences
but not so for his working class brother
and his family
who still live in their hometown of
brooklyn when new york city went into
lockdown
my brother was laid off and his wife was
forced to close her hair salon
when new york city schools closed my
brother had to figure out how to help my
nephew finish
kindergarten through zoom if my brother
wanted to relieve some stress through
recreation
too bad well the fact is this pandemic
has illustrated
what conservative populace have been
saying for years
that the educated elites are almost
completely disconnected
from the way working-class americans
think and how they live
not to mention how propagandistic many
in the medical establishment have become
the new york times just published the
responses to an informal survey
of epidemiologists and it seems that
most
even with the vaccine would never
recommend that we go back to our old
lives ever again
now the answers range from masks for the
next few years
to we'll never go back to our
pre-pandemic freedoms
now remember this is what they're saying
after we'll have spent hundreds of
billions of dollars on vaccines
lost trillions in wealth lost years off
our children's development and education
but still not going back to normal so
what do you think is going on here
has everything become too political is
this all about achieving
the globalist goal of a great reset of
our world economy
the effort whose proponents by the way
use biden's
build back better motto to push their
idea of forced wealth equalization
now americans who care about their
freedoms and our independence
they better start asking questions and
by the way
don't let the experts wave you off by
saying this is what the science says
because i bet most of them either don't
know
or don't care about what the us
constitution says
and that's the angle